vancouver like the rest of north
america's pacific
northwest is sweltering a heat
dome of high-pressure air settling over
the region
like a lid on a pot the 13 million
people living in the affected area much
more accustomed to rain
and moderate temperatures we were
way too hot we went to a couple
different places
looking for air conditioning units and
they were sold out every
everywhere the motel we're staying at
had no ice which was
miserable for me and the heat kicks me
just too hot for me it's over 70 it's
too hot
in parts of canada it has reached nearly
50 degrees celsius
shattering records and potentially
contributing to
dozens of deaths amongst the elderly and
most vulnerable
from power supplies to agriculture
systems are under strain
animals struggling too hi pretty girl
this pregnant deer seeking shelter from
the danger
it's always hard to link one specific
weather event to climate change
but experts say our warming world will
make heat waves like
this one a more frequent more extreme
reality
for millions we now have to redouble our
efforts to address
global warming and the consequences on
people
on on communities and on the landscape
and most importantly i think on the
landscape as we've seen
should we end up having another
difficult fire season that will be
three out of four of the seasons that
i've been premiere have been
record-breaking and no one can plan for
three out of four years being the worst
ever
in northern california tinder dry
forests
are already burning and the heat wave is
starting to spread east across the rest
of america
in this part of the world a long
dangerous summer
stretches ahead hannah thomas peter sky
news